George please could you tell us about
your favorite book
what's the dearest memory you have of it
I don't know that I have a favorite book
I have you know maybe 20 favorite books
and I've read it first thousands of
books I did since I've been a kid I've
been a guy who's had his nose in a book
there's a line that I used in Game of
Thrones that a reader lives a thousand
lives before he dies and the person who
does not read lives only one and I have
read I hadn't lived a thousand lives and
I've learned other planets I've walked
in middle-earth I've ridden with Ivanhoe
in there in the Crusades and and in the
twenties in front of King John I've
adventured with Robin Hood in the forest
I've climbed Mount Everest I've done all
of these things in the pages of the book
and I've gone to distant stars too
because I am a science fiction reader
and writer there are books that I return
to regularly they're not all science
fiction or fantasy
I do reread some of my favorite Jack
Vance books every few years
I do love Toki and of course Lord of the
Rings another book I returned to there
are certain other books that are not SF
I'm a huge fan of The Great Gatsby by f
scott Fitzgerald
that's one book that I returned to
repeatedly some of the best book by
Dickens I think my favorite is A Tale of
Two Cities it was the best of times it
was the worst of times what a great
beginning and then what a great end do
you know is a far far better thing I do
than I have ever done great bittersweet
ending there so yeah I have a lot of
books that I like and the best
my mind the very best books are the ones
that you can reread over and over again
and every time you return to them you
find new things in them and you enjoy
them just as much and that's not that's
only true for a small number of books I
mean a lot of books are very enjoyable
the first time you read them but they
don't repay repeated rereading yes